[Musique]
exceptionnel phénoménal historique la
découverte du tombeau de Toutankhamon
est l'une des plus importantes en
archéologie au 20e siècle
c'est le britannique Howard qui découvre
la somptueuse sépulture
tu as découverte survient en novembre
1922 c'était il y a 100 ans
[Musique]
Toutankhamon devient pharaon à l'âge de
9 ans il règne de 1333 à 1323 avant
Jésus-Christ moins de 10 ans pourtant
c'est l'un des plus connus
son tombeau est érigé en Égypte dans la
Vallée des Rois sur la rive ouest du Nil
il est préservé des pièges pendant des
siècles car son entrée est enseveli sous
les gravats
après 7 ans de recherche infructueuse
l'équipe de Harley Carter s'apprête à
quitter la Vallée des Rois
quand une marche taillée dans le rock
sort de terre c'est l'entrée d'un
escalier une fois les marches libérées
les chercheurs découvrent une porte qui
donne sur un tombeau
le trésor funéraire est une incroyable
richesse quelques 5400 objets sont
répertoriés dont le fameux masque
funéraire en or
le tombeau est si riche qu'il faudra 10
ans pour le dégager et récupérer ses
trésors
plusieurs années après avoir été exhumé
on prélève l'ADN du souverain on apprend
qu'il serait mort de paludisme à l'âge
de 18 ou 19 ans les experts s'accordent
à dire que Toutankhamon n'est pas un
pharaon d'importance
sa célébrité et sans contredit due à la
richesse de sa tombe et peut-être aussi
à la malédiction du pharaon un mythe
développé par la littérature et le
cinéma